vous expliquer comment se déroule un
bike and run alors en fait il s'agit
d'une épreuve où on va avoir un vélo
pour deux athlètes
donc il va y avoir un athlète qui va
courir pendant que son camarade est en
train de se reposer en faisant du vélo à
côté donc le but c'est de se déplacer
bien sûr le plus rapidement possible en
alternant donc un coup c'est le couloir
à qui va courir pendant kloet et sur le
vélo puis le court a pas sur le vélo
pendant que l'autre passe en course à
pied
alors on a plusieurs manières
d'effectuer ses relais on peut les faire
pour ceux qui souhaitent à avoir des
fractions d'efforts très rapide sur des
fractions des phares du coup plus courte
de 50 secondes à une minute
donc là toutes les 50 secondes une
minute vous pourrait se passer le relais
donc ça c'est pour ceux qui souhaitent
engager dans une eau fans haute
intensité et après pour ceux qui sont un
peu plus dans une gestion d'efforts pour
des épreuves longues distances comme le
raid
on peut faire des effractions d'efforts
de 3 à 5 minutes
par contre du coup à d intensité modérée
et ensuite cerep ces efforts là ça peut
être
suivant les niveaux des athlètes ce
plutôt cinq minutes pour l'unss si c'est
peut-être là qui est un peu plus fort ou
trois minutes pour l'autre parent s il a
un petit peu moins fort on peut aussi
adapter la prise de relais en fonction
de la topologie du relief du parcours on
va éviter de changer dans une montée sur
une montée par exemple vaut mieux
laisser vélo meilleur rouleur est comme
ça le coup il va pouvoir faire l'effort
de relance une bosse alors que
généralement dans une bosse le celui qui
en vélo se retrouve un peu un peu plus
en difficulté donc tout le long de cette
bosse vaut mieux que ce soit le
le meilleur rouleur qui prennent le vélo
et ensuite vous est fixé un changement
en haut
en fait ce qui va être très important
c'est surtout que les les deux
communique énormément pour savoir où ils
en sont et de leur état de forme pour
pouvoir réguler justement ces fractions
d'efforts et qui doivent pas forcément
être fixée c'est pas parce qu'on part au
début en se disant on fait d une minute
une minute qu'il faut rester absolument
dans le schéma une minute une minute
jusqu'à la fin ensuite il ya une partie
technique dans la montée du bâti dans la
partie du bike and run s'agit du passage
donc où on va monter sur le vélo et des
cendres donc là il faut aussi s'entendre
avec son coéquipier est ce que je
descends à droite du vélo est ce que je
monte à gauche du vélo parce que ça va
avoir son importance si on descend à
gauche ça va laisser la partie droite du
vélo libre et si on descend à gauche va
se forcément les de côté donc ça
veut dire que si je descends du côté
droit
eh bien il va falloir que je passe le
relais à mon collègue qui sera lui à
gauche puis vélo ça évite de tourner 15
fois autour du vélo
une fois qu'on a passé le vélo emma il
faut cette fois ci monte et monte on a
trois manières de le faire soit on se
met à l'arrêt et on a en jambes son vélo
soit la deuxième manière c'est on va
faire de la trottinette là qu'on va
présenter un pied sur une puis
avec l'élan du vélo juste enjambées pour
passer le pied sur l'autre ou
alors après on va directement sauter sur
la scène important un bike and run c'est
avant tout s'amuser on va toujours ces
disciplines qui se pratique notamment
sur le rsa matin en pleine nature
donc faut profiter pour regarder la
nature pensez à vous hydrater évidemment
donc utiliser les petits la voir qui va
les voir sur les parcours les choses
comme ça et puis l'important surtout
c'est de rester en équipe et de
communiquer entre vous pas de pression
c'est une discipline très fun donc
l'important c'est de s'amuser et d'en
profiter un max on se retrouve au raid
saint martin au mois de juin